good morning John so this video is gonna
be about birth control and statistics if
you're not super down talking about sex
or math or you get the weebly's thinking
about me talking about either of those
things I don't mind if you check out on
this one for those of you who stayed I
remember when I first took sex ed I was
told that condoms had a two percent
failure rate and there's about 25
different ways than you can
misunderstand that statistic so I want
to talk about that first what kind of
failure has condoms do more than one
thing they reduce the chances of
pregnancy but also of disease
transmission or when they say failure do
they mean like a structural failure of
the condom which may or may not result
in pregnancy or disease transmission
well in this case what my sex ed teacher
was talking about and what we're talking
about in this video is unwanted
pregnancy so my teacher was saying when
using a condom perfectly and properly
for vaginal sex there is a 2% chance of
pregnancy occur but like per what I
thought at the time that it was per sex
that makes a certain amount of sense so
like every time you do it you have a 2%
chance of pregnancy and that would be
pretty terrible like that would be just
10 times better than just having
unprotected sex but whenever you read
about unintended pregnancy rates with
birth control that's per year of use not
per individual intercourse so over a
year of perfect proper condom use there
is a 2% chance that a couple will get
pregnant not a couple did just the one
person but you know this actually for me
is a little less good because one the
sexually active person might have way
like 10 times more sex than another
sexually active person the person who
has more sex will be more likely to get
pregnant using only condoms but that's
how it gets measured because for the
most part these statistics aren't meant
to help individuals make individual
decisions they're meant to inform public
health decisions by policy makers but
they get used by individuals because
they're the only stats we have her
active intercourse the odds of pregnancy
decrease about 250 times if you're using
a condom now that's a lot better than
just 10 times and that is a statistic
that as far as I can tell has never been
taught in a sex ed course because I had
to calculate it myself using somewhat
incomplete raw data now in addition to
misunderstanding what the 2% statistic
meant I also misunderstood how
statistics work and I thought that meant
that if there was a 2% chance of
unintended pregnancy that if you did it
a hundred times
there would be two pregnancies that's
not how probabilities work you have a 2%
chance ever
years we have a 2% chance the first year
a 2% chance the tenth year 2% chance the
hundredth year though not actually on
the hundredth year seems unlikely every
year it's a new roll of the dice the
statistics does allow us to measure
probabilities for multiple rolls of the
dice so if you go for two years you
multiply 0.98 by 0.98 to get your odds
of not getting pregnant if you use
condoms perfectly every time for 10
years your odds become about 20% that
you will get pregnant and over 20 years
that becomes 1 in 3 the final and vital
way that this statistic is misunderstood
is that perfect use is very different
from typical use and when we measure
typical use we see that condoms result
in pregnancy about 20% of years in which
people only use condoms that is a very
different number from 2% typical use is
how the average person uses birth
control and you may not be an average
person nobody really is if there's a way
to mess up people often find that way
which is why new forms of birth control
like implants or IUDs if they work for
that particular person have had a really
substantial impact on unwanted
pregnancies in the world and in America
these technologies typical use is the
exact same as their perfect use because
they're just always doing the thing
they're supposed to do and they're also
even more effective than perfect use of
condoms so neither of them to be clear
protect against diseases obviously John
I made this video because I was really
confused when I was given these
statistics I wish that I had had more
than the basketball coach begrudgingly
parroting some politicized curriculum at
me hopefully the existence of the
internet and the continuing work of
scientists to understand this stuff will
allow people to get better information
and make better decisions even as people
continue to fight to hide this stuff
John I'll see you on Tuesday